when he looked east
he saw the past
old tired
dead
but when he looked west
he saw the future
gold in the ground
gold in the fields and no dragons in the
sky but his
he and his sisters rhaenys and visenya
flew over the great continent ostensibly
visitors to a strange land
but when aegon returned
he ordered construction of a massive
table carved in the shape of westeros
with all the notable rivers and
mountains that they had seen
a personal map of the seven kingdoms
then ruled by seven squabbling families
[Music]
house durrandon held the stormlands from
their seat at storm's end due south of
dragonstone
house horror of the iron islands had
also conquered and enslaved the
riverlands and ruled them from harrenhal
a monstrous castle rising on the shore
of the god's eye
how stark held the frozen wasteland of
the north the oldest largest and
emptiest of the kingdoms
house lannister held the westerlands the
wealthiest kingdom thanks to their gold
mines
house gardener held the reach the second
wealthiest kingdom thanks to their crops
house aaron held the veil
or rather the veil held them the
mountains were impossible except through
the bloody gate which had never been
taken
house martel held the deserts of dawn
probably because no one else wanted them
together the seven kingdoms made
westeros a realm that wasn't yet around
ruled by great families who didn't know
what greatness was
aegon would teach them
though house derenden titled themselves
storm kings they were little more than
gusts
their kingdom in the stormlands had been
doddering to its end for the past few
centuries helped along by other houses
most of all by house horror who were
nearly finished with a monstrous castle
at harrenhal
too large and too costly a seat to rule
only the riverlands
king argilac knew where the ironborn
would soon turn
you'd think a king who wanted to keep
his crown would be wary of a man with
fire breathing monsters but king argilac
darunden wasn't called the arrogant for
nothing
determined to arrest his family's
decline he sent an envoy to dragonstone
to enlist aegon targaryen and his
dragons against his enemies
in exchange agalek offered lands he
didn't have and a wife aegon didn't need
for as the valerians did aegon had wed
his elder sister visenya
then as the valerians didn't he took the
younger rhaenys as well
two sisters two wives
perhaps that's why he was so keen to get
off dragonstone
aegon countered argilac with courtesy
he sent his own envoy requesting that
princess durrandon's hand be given
instead to aegon's closest friend and
rumored half brother orris baratheon
argoluck answered with a box and a note
these are the only hands your boss shall
have of me
inside the box were the hands of aegon's
envoy
how long had aegon been waiting for such
a pretext
as his army prepared to sail ravens flew
to every great lord of the seven
kingdoms
all bore the same message from this day
forth there would be but one king in
westeros
those who bent the knee to aegon of
house targaryen would keep their lands
and titles
those who took up arms against him would
be thrown down humbled and destroyed
poor old argilac he couldn't even match
aegon in arrogance
aegon landed at the mouth of the
blackwater river and raised a primitive
aegon fort in the disputed land between
haran's and argilac's kingdom so that
neither could decide whose problem he
was
adopting the costumes of the seven
kingdoms aegon unfurled his own banner
with the red three-headed dragon
breathing fire upon a black field
visenya crowned him with a ruby-studded
circlet of valerian steel
while reigners hailed him as the first
high king the continent had seen since
the dawn age
as his lords and the gathered locals
cheered him aegon named his loyal friend
to a small council led by oris baratheon
whom he called my strong right hand
the title stuck and abbas became the
first hand of the king
but for now aegon's kingdom contained
only a rocky island and a handful of
fields
the other kings had larger armies ships
castles and thousands of years of rule
but aegon had dragons
he had chosen for the words of his house
fire and blood
before he was done
the rivers fields and skies would turn
red
aaron of hazor inherited a kingdom that
stretched from the iron islands to the
triton
too great a kingdom to rule from a
castle's shittiest pike
for 40 years his ironborn plundered the
riverlands for stone timber and slaves
to build the seat worthy of him
legend has it that masons laid the final
stone in arnold on the very day that
aegon landed in westeros
could have been a divine owen
could have been the masons wants to [ __ ]
before the dragons got there
they weren't the only ones
at aegon's approach parents river lords
revolted led by house charlie
i thought heron noticed
harrenhal could repel an army of a
million men
no ladder could summon its walls and no
ram could shatter them the castle was as
impregnable as an old mate's [ __ ]
aaron shut his gates around himself his
sons and his ironborn
and waited for aegon's army to drain
back into the muck
when aegon finally saw the monstrous
castle he asked for parley
herring granted it
valeria had been the greatest empire the
world had ever seen
aaron wanted to piss on its ashes
yield now and you may remain as lord of
the iron islands
yield now
and your sons will live to rule after
you
you see my army outside your walls
you see my dragons
what is outside my walls is of no
concern those walls are strong and thick
dragons fly
but stone doesn't burn
when the sun sets
your line shall end
aaron spat and returned to his castle
once inside he promised lance riches and
tally's daughters to whoever could bring
down aegon or his dragon
as the sun sank below the horizon all of
heron's men patrolled the battlements
hearing wings in every gust of wind
but the moon rose and sank
and no dragon appeared
while the ironborn were ringing the
battlements aegon drove his dragon
balerion higher and higher in the night
sky so that even the great castle of
herron hall looked like an ant hill
below them
then they plunged straight into the
castle well inside the guarded walls
the five towers of heron hall reached
towards aegon like a hand
valerion opened his mouth and bathed all
the fingers in flame
harren was right
stone doesn't burn but men do
even when they're ironborn
the dragon blasted my ancestors into ash
that choked the survivors when they
screamed
harren's soldiers leapt from the
battlements and died
they huddled against the walls and died
they fled across the yard and died
aaron and his sons took shelter inside
the castle
stone didn't burn
but as valerian blasted it with fire it
glowed wide hot
the world's greatest castle became the
world's greatest oven
baking the last of house aura within it
outside the castle walls the towers of
heron hall glowed red against the night
and began to twist and melt like five
huge candles with liquid stone trickling
down their sides like wax
the next morning aegon forged a new
riverlands
he named the rebel edmund tully as his
lord paramount of the trident and had
the other riverlords swear him fealty as
their new liege
for centuries house horror had
terrorized the riverlands
under house tully the riverlands would
at last return to peace and prosperity
after the castle cooled enough to allow
men inside aegon ventured into the ruin
he'd made of herron hall
he saw the ashen bodies the scorched
stone and the mangled and melted swords
of his former enemies to his men's
confusion he ordered these useless
swords collected and sent to his aegon
fort
while aegon marched on harrenhal after
his coronation
auris baratheon had taken most of his
forces and his queen rhaenys with her
dragon south to deal with the excuse for
the invasion argilac the arrogant king
of the stormlands
argilac had his seat at storm's end a
castle considered the most impregnable
in westeros after hiron hall
arguelac may have been arrogant but he
wasn't stupid or a coward his lords
advised him to shut his gates and wait
out the siege
but he'd heard what had happened at
harrenhal and refused to die a suckling
pig cooked in his own castle
he would meet victory or defeat the same
way
with sword in hand
he called his banners and marched to
meet auras baratheon in the field
thanks to reiner's dragon meraxis aureus
knew argilac was coming how many men he
had and how fast he marched
so auras simply seized the high ground
and dug in on the hills to wait for
argelac
as the two armies approached the wind
rose to meet them and the rain poured
from the sky a gale which would give the
battle its name
the last storm
king argilac's lords urged him to wait
for the weather to die down
but a storm king saw that the rain was
blowing into the faces of the baratheon
men on their hills
and agilecard numbered the baratheon
host two to one
with four times as many knights and
heavy horse
argilac attacked
three times argilac led his knights
against the baratheon line but the hills
were steep and the rain had beat the
earth to mud
the war horses founded and slipped and
the charges collapsed
the battle seemed lost
until argilac ordered his spearmen up
the hill
blinded by the rain the baratheons
didn't see them until it was too late
one hill fell then another
and another
until only one remained in the baratheon
center
if argilac could break through there
he could split the invading army and
flank both halves
argilac and his men charged and the
baratheon line broke
revealing queen rhaenys
vanguard burst into flame and his men
panicked
the victory charge fell into chaos and
aguila himself was thrown from his horse
but he didn't yield
when auris baratheon arrived he found
the old king holding off half a dozen
men another half dozen dead at his feet
oris dismounted to meet the king on
equal footing and offered argilac one
final chance to yield
argilac cursed him instead
as the storm raged around them the
grizzled old warrior and the bearded
upstart fought for life and kingdom
in the end
aguilar got his wish
he died
sword in hand
as word of argilac's death spread his
lords and knights threw down their
swords and fled
ory sent his vanguard rode to storm's
end to claim argilac's castle for aegon
only to find the gates barred and the
walls manned
argilac's daughter had assumed his crown
and the new storm queen was as fond of
yielding as her father
she declared that auris would win only
bones blood and ashes here
but her man were weaker than her
and that night oris found argilac's
daughter delivered gagged chained and
naked to his camp
argilac had refused to give auris her
hand
now orris could have any part of her he
wished
but auris unchained the girl wrapped his
cloak around her and poured her a glass
of wine
he told her he would take the arms
banner and words of house durrandon to
honor her father's courage in the last
storm
conveniently orris had none of his own
to discard first
the crown stag became the sigil of house
baratheon and storms end their seat
argilac's daughter would even remain in
her home though as a lady instead of the
princess
the stormlands were now aegons
and as tribute aegon demanded the swords
of the men oris had defeated
for what purpose
iris didn't know
aegon now ruled two of the seven
kingdoms but he would no longer be able
to take the rest piece meal
for the first time in thousands of years
the kings put aside their squabbles and
joined forces against a common enemy
my ancestor king lauren of house
lannister was head of the wealthiest
family in the seven kingdoms
when king lauren joined his forces to
mourn of house gardener king of the
reach
they had the mightiest army in history
a so-called iron fist
to break the would-be conqueror
but while an iron fist can smash a man's
face in battle you'd look silly hunting
birds or beasts with it
an aegon had a creature there was both
the kings had never even seen a dragon
let alone fought one they had fooled
each other for thousands of years and
victory always went to the larger army
surely a force five times that of
aegon's could manage one dragon
but aegon arrived with three
still the lannisters and gardeners hoped
for victory the battlefield they chose
was a wide plane with firm ground and
clear skies perfect for archers and
mounted cavalry
but neither of the kings sped a thought
for why the ground was firm
there had been no rain for a fortnight
which meant all the wheat and grass on
it were bone dry
perfect for dragons
at first the kings looked like they
would emerge victorious
when the horn blew for battle their
armies swept around aegon's flanks and
there are iron fists of mounted knight
smashed through his center before the
dragons could even enter the fray
but then aegon and his sisters took
flight and unleashed their dragons not
on the soldiers but on the dry fields
all around them
the iron fists
unclenched and became a hand
outstretched for mercy
as aegon promised he had none
more than four thousand men died in the
fires another thousand escaping from
tens of thousands returned home as
monsters burned and scarred beyond
recognition
house gardener never returned at all
the field of fire as the singers call it
claimed the last of the gardener line
and house tyrell rose in their stead as
lords of the reach and wardens of the
south
as for my illustrious ancestor when king
lawrence saw the battle was lost he rode
through a wall of flame and smoke to
safety
or at least to a heroic capture day
later where he laid his sword before
aegon and knelt
aegon true to his words spared him and
confirmed house lannister as lords of
casterly rock and wardens of the west
why wouldn't he
the lannister always pays his debts
and now we owed our lives to the crown
that was worth centuries of subservience
at least
besides aegon had a fetish for
collecting swords not
he added lawrence to the pile his men
had retrieved from the field of fire and
sent them back to the aegonford
with most of the south in aegon's hands
the best chance to throw back the
conqueror now lay with the north
if we cared enough to try
unlike our southern rivals the stark
kings of winter didn't forge the north
into one kingdom for glory or gold there
is little of either here but to survive
alone in westeros the north remembered
when worse than dragons lay waste to
armies
thousands of years ago the sun set on
the realms of men and the long night
began a new race emerged from the ice
and snow the white walkers they demanded
no crown offered no terms spared no life
and the dead marched with them with
humanity facing extinction a stark
sought out the children of the forest
most ancient beings in westeros and
convinced them to ally with the men they
once fought
together the two races pushed the
walkers back into the land of always
winter and sealed it off from the seven
kingdoms with the wall
300 miles of ice stone and earth rising
nearly 700 feet tall
to guard it they established the night's
watch a brotherhood sworn to defend the
living from the dead whose vows are
raised both titles and crimes
after the long night the north tried to
forget it belonged to a continent
perhaps through pride perhaps through
sheer ignorance you never can tell with
the north but as news of aegon's dragons
spread
torrensta the king of winter
knew he couldn't forget westeros any
longer
and summoned his lords to winterfell
many fools shrugged off the threat while
the rest placed wages on how long the
south would take to burn
tauren silenced them with a command to
assemble their armies and descend from
the north in force
as the kings of the rock and the reach
burned on the field of fire the greatest
northern force since the long night
crossed the neck into the riverlands
but when king tauren arrived at the
trident he saw on the opposing riverbank
the combined strength of all aegon's
conquered kingdoms
a force larger than tauren's own by half
and with three dragons
that night king tauren called the
conference of all his lords and advisers
wanted to fight and trust northern valor
to carry the day
and burn on the triton
the wisest of them wanted to withdraw to
moat kaelin the fortress which had
thrown back every southern invasion
and burn there
one suicidal lord even wanted to ambush
aegon's camp in the dark and kill the
dragons as they slept or at the very
least their riders
it's hard to tell what would have been
his fate
burning
beheading
dismemberment
perhaps all three
my ancestors listened to their council
and in the morning crossed the trident
under a flag of pales then king tauren
of house stark laid his ancient crown at
aegon's feet and was named lord of
winterfell and warden of the north
and the king who knelt
he had no choice and thanks to him our
soldiers returned to their homes whole
and unharmed
the swords that aegon took from them
were not twisted burnt or mangled
yet
the veil of aaron was the last of the
great kingdoms left
old and proud house aaron did what they
always did in times of strife
they shut the bloody gate sealing off
the veil
then the queen regent shara of house
aaron retreated with her son the boy
king ronald into the eerie their
family's impregnable fortress
from the top of their mountain they
could look down on westeros far below
its problems hidden beneath the clouds
but one day queen shara entered the
outer courtyard to find her young son
sitting on the knee of visenya targaryen
and ogling her dragon vega beside her
just as he'd ask for another cake at
dinner
little king ronald asked his mother if
he could go flying on the nice lady's
dragon
visenya smiled at shara
so shara imagined did vega
remembering her manners shara asked if
she could have visenya brought some wine
or food she must be tired after such a
long flight
but visenya demured
bored with his mother's pleasantries
ronald demanded an answer
poor boy
he didn't even understand the question
sarah hesitated for a moment then asked
for zenya as a mother if it was safe for
the boy
visenya assured her it was
what choice did shara have
whilst her son circled the castle she
collected his little ringlet her own
region's coronet and the ancient falcon
crown of mountain and vale which the
aarons had worn for thousands of years
ronald had taken to the sky as a king
but he landed as a lordling
perhaps he considered his ancient rights
a fair trade for a few minutes of flight
as a little boy would
more likely he didn't even notice the
three crowns at visenya's feet
or recognize the swords of his garrison
beside them
the heads of westeros had bowed to aegon
but its heart still beat free
old town the center of the faith of the
seven
there dwelt the high septon the father
of the faithful who commanded the
obedience of all westeros save the
savages of the north and their old gods
when aegon had landed in westeros the
high septon had locked himself in the
starry sept and fasted for seven days
and seven nights one for each of his
gods
all he received for his trouble was the
divine wisdom that if old town took up
arms against the dragon
the city would burn
faithful and faithless alike
after the submission of house stark
aegon marched towards old town stealing
himself for another battle
but he found the gates open with the
high septon welcoming him
the pious fool even had the arrogance to
grant what aegon had already won
and anointed the last valyrian as aegon
of house targaryen
first of his name king of the andals and
the first men
lord of the seven kingdoms
and protector of the realm
as if titles meant anything to a man
before whom time itself now bowed
the maesters would hence divide all
history into before and after conquest
most expected aegon to stay and make old
town his seat
but soon after his coronation
aegon returned to the mouth of the
blackwater river where he had first set
foot on westeros
a small town had since sprouted around
his primitive fort
to honor their new master the locals
dubbed it king's landing
though it looked more fit for a hedge
night with wooden palisades muddy
streets
and piles of mangled swords carted in
from every corner of the conquest
but when aegon made it his court
wood became stone
black mud was buried beneath a red keep
and the collected swords of aegon's foes
were blasted by dragon fire and became a
seat fit for the conqueror and the
greatest dynasty this world has ever
known
house targaryen
my family
my throne
or so it should have been
but while aegon titled himself lord of
the seven kingdoms in reality he held
only six
the seventh dawn had never knelt
visenya had flown into the veil and
returned with its crown
mimicking her sister rhaenys had flown
over the enemy force holding the passers
into dawn and landed in the castle of
its ruling lady princess maria of house
martel
maria was 80 years old fat bald and
blind behind her back many sniggered at
her as the yellow toad of dawn
the beautiful renise probably thought as
much when they met she demanded princess
mary a neil to her brother aegon though
she allowed that an account of merrier's
age and health the simple vow of
submission would do
but the princess told the queen that the
targaryens weren't wanted in dawn and no
martel would ever bow bend or break no
matter how badly they burned
could have mounted her dragon right then
and roasted maria in the castle as her
brother had done at harrenhal but
whatever she saw in mary's eyes scared
her right back to king's landing with a
dragon's tail between its legs
after aegon's coronation
rhaenys returned to dawn with aegon and
visenya
and their dragons
but no armies met them in the field and
no lords defied them in their castles
as the dragons approached dawn simply
emptied
house martel had learned from harrenhal
and the field of fire the dragons were
unbeatable in battle but wars were more
than battles
unopposed aegon claimed dawn for his own
but as soon as he returned to king's
landing his castles were hurled off
towers and his royal garrison vanished
in the desert never to be seen again
except perhaps when the winds change and
the sands cough up old bones and armor
renise returned on meraxis intent on
revenging herself against maria martell
but dawn was no longer empty
the dornish kept maria's promise
and fought even while burning under
dragonflame
and they won
one day a bowl pierced the eye of
maraxxus and knocked the dragon out of
the sky
house martel remained unbroken
unlike the unfortunate rainers
in their wrath aegon and visenya set
flame to every castle and city but
sunspear trying to turn the people
against house martel
but the dornish stayed loyal and when
aegon returned to king's landing he
found assassins waiting for him in the
streets of his own capital
if not for visenya the conqueror would
not have enjoyed his conquest for very
long
from then on the king and his family
would be guarded by the seven greatest
knights in the realm
the king's guard
when maria died in her sleep her weak
and tired son sued for peace
but old maria had exhausted aegon as
well
and he granted the request
the targaryen still wanted dawn and
eventually they would have it but not at
the point of a sword
they would buy it the same way great
lords buy anything
with a daughter